.
>> ANK YOU VERYMUCH FOR THAT
ANSWER
>> SENATOUL.
>> DR. FAUC THE IDEATHAT A
GORNMENT OFFICIAL LI
YOURSE WOULCLAIM
UNERALLY TO REPRESENSCIENCE AND
ITICM OF SCIENCITSE
QUE DANGERS.
CENTRAPLANNING WHETHER  THE
ECONOMOROF SCIENCE ISRISK
BECAUSE OF THE LL ILT OF THE PL.
WOULDN BE SO TASTIC
IF IT WE ONE POTION
PEORIA.
THE MISTAKE WOULD ONLY FECT
THOSPATITS AND WHEN THE
PLANNEIS A GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL KE YOURSELF O
RULEBY MANDE, THE ERRORS
ARCOOUNDED ANBECOMEMUCH
RE RMFUL.
A PLANNER WHO BELIEVES HE
THSCNCE LEADS TO AN
ARGANCTHAT JUSTIFIES IN HIS
ND USING GOVERNMENT RESOURS
TOSMEAR AND TODESTY THE REPUTAT
WHO DISAEE WITHHIM.
IN  EMAIEXCHANGE WITH DR.
COLLS I OTE DIRECTLY FROM
THE EML.
CREATE A QUK AN
DESTATG PUISHETAKEDOWN
OF REPROMINT
EPEMIOGISTS FR HAARD,
OXFORD AND STANFORD
ERE E A LOOFFINISHING EP
EM OL YIFTS THER
THEY E FRINGE.ML THAT
MEDIATELTHERE IS THISTA
WN FORT.
IT DOESN'T NJURE UP E AGE OF A .
INSTD OFENGAGI THEM  THE
MERITSYOU THOUGHTO EAR
TH AS FRGE AND TAKETHEM
DOWN
NOT IN JOURNALS, IN LAPRES.
THIS  NOT ON ANTHET CALL
TO THE IEIFICMETHOD IT IS
THCHP POLITICS AND IT IS
REEHENSIBLE DR. FAUCI.
DO YOU THK IT'S APPROPRIATTO US
ATTACK SCNTIS TH DISAGR
WITH YOU?
>> THE EMAIL YOU ARE REFERRG
TO WAS ANEMAIOF DR. LLIN
TO ME.
IF YOU OK AT THE EMAI
>>THAT YORESPOND TOAND
SAID I CADO IT.
WE GOT SOMETHING.
>> , I THINK INOOUSHL
FAION, SENATOR,YOU ARE
STORTINGEVERHING ABOUT ME.
>> DID YOU EVER JECT TOHIS
CHARACTERITIONF THEM AS
FRINGE.DID YOU ITE BACK AND SAY
THEYARE NOT FRGE AND IT
ULD BE NEATME TODO THAT
YOU RESPONDED TH YOWOULD DO
.
U IMMEDIELY T ANARTICLE
RED D SENT IT BACK AND SAID
OK, I'VE T THEM D I
ILED THEM IN WIRED.
THAT'S NOT AT WENTON.
THERYOU GO AGAIN.
YOU DO THE SA THING EVERY
HEARIN
>> TH WAS UR RESP.
IT SN'TTHE ONLY TIME.
YOURDESIRE TO TAKE DO PEOPLE>>Y
SENAR.
YOU ARINCOECT ALMO
EVERYTNG YOU SAY.
>> IS WASN'T THON TIMEUR DERE T
WHO SAGR WITH YOU DIDN
STOP THER
YOU CONSPIREWITH PETEDAZAQ
AND OTR MEERS OF THE
SCIEIFIC COMMUNITY TH WROTE
OPINION PIEC FOR NATURE, VE
OF THEM SIED A PAPER
NATURE.
17 GNED A PAPER THAT CALL
IT CONSPIRACY EORY
THE IDEA THAT THE RUS COD HAVE .
DO U INK RDS LIKE
CONSPIRACYTHEO SHOULDBE IN
A SCIENTIFIC PER?
>> SETOR, I NEVER USEDAT
WORD EN I WAS REFERRING  ITYOU
EVERYTHING.
>> DID YOU COMMUNICE TH THFIVE
OPINN PIECE IN TUREWHERE
THEY WEREDESCBING>> THIS WAS NO.
>> D YOU TALKTH ANY THOSE IENTL
YOKEEP DISTORTI THE
TRH.
IS STUNNING
DID U LK  ANY OF THE SCIENTIS .
>> YES.
>> WH WERETHEY LLINYOU
IVATY.
>> YOU ARE GOINBA TO TH ORIGINA
PELE TOLOOKAT EVER
POSSIBILITWI ANPEN MIND
T LY ARE YOU DISTORNG IT,
YOARMPLETELY TURNG IT
OUND
>> MOST THSCIEISTS O
CAME TO PRATELAND SAY
NO WATHIS CA FROM THLAB?
OR WAS ERE INITIAL PRESSION
DR. GARY D OTHE INVOLVED
WAS THERINITIAL IMPRESSI
THATIT LOOKED SUICIOUS FOR A
VIRUS THAT CAMEFROMA LAB?
SENATO  ARE HEREAT A
COMMITTEE TO LOOKAT A VIRUS NOT
0,000 PELE D THPURPE
OF THE MMITE WATO TRY D
GET THGS T HOWE CAN HELP
TO GETHE AMERICANPUBLIC.YOU KEE
RSONAL ATTAS ONME THAT
VE ABSOLUTE NO RELEVANCTO
ALITY.
>>YOU THINK YBODY HAS HAD
MO INUENCE OV OUR RESPONSE TO I?
DOU THINK IT'S A EAT
SUCCESS WHAT HAS HAPPED SO
FAR?
DOYOU THINTHE LOCKDOWNS HAVE
BEEN GOODFOR OUKIDSAND
SLOWED DOWN THDEATRIGHT?MORE OP
PRESENT BIDETHANPRESIDENT
UMP.ARE YOU THE CHITECT,THLEAD
ARCHITECFOR E RESPONSE FROM
E GOVERNMENT AND W 800,000
OPLEHAVE DI.
YOU THINK IT  A WINNING
CCESAT YOU VE VOCATED
FOR GOVERNME?
SENATOR, RST OF AL IF YOU LOOK
SAID I ACCUSEME OFIN A WATELLIN
.
EVERYTHING THAT I SAIDHAS BEEN
IN SUPPORT  E CDC
GUIDELINES.
WEAR A MASKGET OSTED,
>>AND YOU'VE DE ITCOERCIVE
ANDONE BYMAATE.
U'VE ADVOCATEYO
INFAIBLE OPION  DICTATED
BY W.
SO AGAIN, DAM CHAIR I
WOULD KE A COUP OF MITES.THIS HE
YOU PERSONALLYATTA MEAND
WI ABSOLULY NOA SHREOF
EVIDCE  ANYTHING YOU SAY.
I ULD LIKE TOKE SOMETHINCLEATO
COMMTEE.HE IS DOING TH FOR POTI.
WHATYOU NEED TO DO IS-- HE
SA IN FRT OF THIS COMMITE.
>> YOU THK YOUR TAKEWN OF PROMI
NOPOLITICAL?
>> U KNOWWHAT I'M GOING TO
SAY.
>>TANG DOWN 93 OMINENT
EPIDIOLOGISTS.>>SENATOR UL.
I WILL ALLOW DR. FAUCI
RESPOND.
WE HA A NUMBER OF SENARS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ASQUESTIONS
AND I WOD LI M TOBE AB
REOND.
>> SO THE LAST TIMEWE HAD
COMMTEE OR THE TIMEFOREHE
WAS ACCUNG  OF BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH OF 4
5 MILLION PEOP WHICH
IRREONSIE.
Y ISHE DOINAT?
TWO REASONS WHY THAT IS ALLY BA
AT 'RE ALL TRNG TO
HERE TODAY IS T OUARMS
ARND THE IDEMIC AND
NDEM WE'RE ALINWITH,
NOT SOTHING IMARY.NUMBER TWO, WN
HE GETS OUAND ACCUSES MEOF
THINGS THAT ARCOMPTELY
TRUE IS THAT ALL OF SUDDEN
THAT KINDLS THAZIES OUT THERE A
MY LI, HASSMENTS OF MY
FALY, ANMYCHILDREN WITH
OBSCENE PHONE LLS BECAUSE PEOPL
THAT'S E WAIT GO, I CAN
TAKE THE HI
LL, IT MAS A DIFFENCE
BEUSE  SOME OF YOU MAY
KN, JUST ABT THREOR FOUR
EKS AGO  CEMBER 21stA
PERSON WAS ARREED WHWAS ON THEI
WASHINGTOND.C. AT A SPEED
OP  IO AND EY ASKED --
THE POCE KED HIM WHERE
WAGOG ANHE WAS GOINTO WASHINGT,
FAUCAND THEYFOUNIN HICAANAR-15
AMMUNITION CAUSHE THINKS
YBE I'M LLING PELE.
I ASD MYSE WHY ULD
SENATOR WANT   TH?
SO GO TORANDPAULWEBSITE D
YOU SEE FIRE DR. FAUCI TH A
TTLE BOTHATSAYS CONTBUTE
HERE.
U N DO $5, 0, $20, $1.YOU ARE M
EPIDEMIC R UR POLITICAL GAIN.>>
ATTAED YOUR COLLEAGUESIN A
POTICALLY PREHSIBLE WA
TO ECK THEIR RETATI.YOU WON'T D.
WEL CONTIN TH HEARING.
WE VE NUMB OF QUTIONS.>> ONE MO.
>>DR. FAUCI APECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE T WEVE A NUMB
OF QUESTIONS FROM NATO AND
WE  HAVE SECO ROUND AND I'BEINAE